hey I'm Kristian harloff and I'm Tiffany
Smith our guest this week is the star
blaze of glory Napoleon Dynamite amongst
tons of other things we've got John
heater sir done we're super excited to
have you here with us but what was it
that really made you come in I came here
because I like movies and fake popcorn
not gonna tell that's what they said and
this is on the Internet and my kids know
way more than I mean about Internet so I
should be on the Internet what they said
John I don't know if you know or not we
actually do bets we're a little
different than most movies yeah every
week on the box-office last week's
weekly wager was just how much ant-man
would make I guessed 79 million
Christian you guessed 85 million I can
actually help you with this because I
know it made 58 million last week so I
totally know normally I'd be very upset
however I see this smug look on my face
you did any fun not really our guest
last week Dan bet for me since Christian
is stuck in slow motion Dan you get to
make his wager I like him getting
punished so I'm gonna say like 20 bucks
you had someone else bet which is
against the rules
we're on an official show we have to
like follow the rules I'm sorry you have
to you want to be punished are this from
Twitter you guys that the loser should
have to get a massage from a creepy
clown
ah alright she's losing her mind is so
good the Internet let's talk about next
week's wager I happen to think it's
gonna be pixels Adam Sandler Peter
Dinklage here's a clip
I believe that's some alien life force
sent down real-life video games to
attack us it's probably gonna make about
49 million I think that pixels will come
in with 50 million
I think the loser should do now next
week I'll put it on Twitter in the
comments below on YouTube I'm like I
don't know what's creepier the clown or
how much John is enjoying it can we just
have him leave like serious red cloud oh
you did a good job though you really
kicked out
we'll do a massage later in the green
room or something
you were great marvels ant-man some
people think that this movie bombed with
6500 it's 58 million whatever made I
disagree I think this is a small heist
film it was a comedy it was on par from
what Captain America the affair small
heist film and a comedy negate the fact
that it didn't 100 200 million Marvel in
the title will expect it you can expect
it maybe but it doesn't make it it still
doesn't make it a bomb we've had some
huge films open up this summer so
comparing it to something like Jurassic
world or you know even trainwreck I did
think that Ant Man was gonna do a lot
better
well I felt the same way like I thought
ant-man was actually gonna make a little
bit more only because of the marvel okay
Marcus Brown is back he's our one shot
the game that we're gonna play is called
Tagget I'm gonna give you guys a tagline
from some famous movies and you guys
have to guess what movie it's from but
since we have you as a guest today Jon
we wanted to do a special Tagget cuz he
created one of the most iconic dance
scenes in a movie
did you see my dance numbers I have not
watched a lot of dance dancing to the
beat of their hearts something with
hearts dancing to the beat of their
hearts I feel like that was kind of a
tie okay next one lose definitely beyond
pride beyond rivalry beyond tradition
predator and West Side Story what am i
doing oh stop stop stop up Southie art
stop the yard what a feeling are we
tried up yeah this one's just funny
dance man work all day work it all night
oh yeah I knew that you fast yes
seriously what the nightmare version of
Magic Mike this is the last one guys
tiebreaker
if you could meet the system break it
beat it oh right um breakin to electric
bugaloo
right so Johnson see one you get to spin
the winners we win
we'll get see hear or do and the wheel
will decide all right yep like take a
puta now oh whatever I want to do story
time and so when the Shepherd's went out
there as usual the robbers came and like
normally they would run away and fear
but this time damn is it No
thank you guys so much and a big THANK
YOU to Jon Heder for joining us on this
week's episode make sure you guys follow
him on Twitter at Peter John and check
out pickle and peanut on Disney XD this
fall and make sure that you subscribe to
this channel here and make sure that you
download the Fandango movie clip app on
your smartphone and join us back here
next week for your great